en 1937 la capitale accueille
l'exposition internationale des arts et
des techniques appliquées à la vie
moderne
deux ans avant que n'éclate le second
conflit mondial 45 nations de
l'allemagne nazie à l'italie fasciste en
passant par l'urss s'y retrouve
ce qui fait aussi la particularité de
cette exposition séquelles à vie
le beau et la technique donc il ya des
pavillons emblématique et d en pavillon
aussi qu'ils resteront notamment le
palais de tokyo et un des palais qui est
derrière nous également le palais du
trocadéro au sein de la bibliothèque
universitaire à guyancourt les visiteurs
peuvent découvrir des clichés inédits
réalisés par l'architecte paysagiste
achille duchêne et conservées jusque là
par son arrière petit fils ou genève
acteur principal de l'expression de 37
ans plus une photographie il est le
responsable
l'exposition et photographiques depuis
chez lui où il était de rue à saint paul
il photographie de l'évolution devant le
palais de tokyo et dans tous les
bâtiments de l'exposition 37
donc il a un rôle prépondérant on voit
rarement l'explosion c'est un long voile
expo terminer avec ces pavillons mais là
on voit l'exploit en train de se faire
évidemment on n'a pas plu tout
reproduire on a laissé quelques clichés
originaux on a évidemment reproduit sur
des grands panneaux quelques photos qui
nous semblait tout à fait emblématique
mais évidemment après il ya d'autres
aspects que nous abordons par ailleurs
un angle d'approché rare qui permettent
aux étudiants et au grand public
d'aborder à la fois l'aspect culturel
mais aussi politique alors que la france
vient de retirer sa candidature pour
l'exposition universelle de 2025 le
public peut donc redécouvrir celle de
1937 la dernière organisée sur notre
territoire et qui entendait promouvoir
la paix